Speaker 1: We had another insane weekend of
the conspiracy mind virus that is plaguing the
American right wing, its conspiracies everywhere
you look. Let's take a little tour through it
on the Maria Bartiromo program yesterday morning
on Fox. Marsha Blackburn showed up Senator Marsha
Blackburn and claimed that Joe Biden is about
to replace Kamala Harris, which the president
can't actually do. But Senator Marsha
Blackburn doesn't seem to care. And, of course,
Maria Bartiromo now loves conspiracy theories.
Speaker 5: Senator, is there anything you want
to say about Kamala Harris? She
was given the role of acting,
Speaker 1: by the way. Why is there music and
why does Maria Bartiromo have to yell over
the music? Just a production question.
Speaker 5: Then when Joe Biden got his
collapsed coffee last week, Colin? Yeah, and
I think when you look at what she has done,
she has failed at every task that she's been
given. That's why there are many in the White
House who are so frustrated with her. It's going
to be interesting to see. Interesting to see
who they push forward, to take her place.
Speaker 1: You know what? And you know,
some people in the comments said, Oh, she's
referring to in Biden's reelection in 2024.
That's not what they mean. Many of them don't
even believe Biden's running for reelection.
So she's talking about who are they going to
replace Kamala with? Then we go to something
really bizarre. Steve Bannon appearing on some
kind of very strange. It appears to be a Chinese
propaganda show. It's not even clear what this is
and pushing vaccine conspiracies about segregation
and very, very strange stuff of religion.
Speaker 4: And so I think that this is very
powerful. You see, every day with a new federal
state, remember the new federal states only a
year and a half old. It's only 18 months old. And
look, look, look as what's happened today. We're
commemorating the third anniversary of really
the rule of law of the of the great presentation
we had that day at the Pier Hotel. And look how
much power that the Rule of Law Foundation, Rule
of Law Society, the whistleblower movement. You've
changed history right here today. You can hear the
protest in this city and the protest is about
anti-vaccine, right? And it's not that people
are anti-vax is that they're vaccine hesitant,
right? And the reason they're vaccine hesitant
is that the information hasn't been put out about
exactly what happened in the Wuhan lab. What what
is this virus really about and why therapeutics,
prophylactic therapeutics like hydroxychloroquine
or ivermectin, or all these other attributes and
what they can do. And so the whole world right now
is questioning whether it's in Europe or in
France or in Austria or the United States is a big
protest here today about about American citizens
who are, you know, American born right, who are
protesting the these overreaching mandates to take
Speaker 1: what on earth is Bannon talking about
Speaker 4: if your freedom away? So I think if
you look at the new federal state and what has
been able to accomplish in 18 months and what the
whistleblower movement and what genies and JTV,
and particularly the rule of law just in three
years, remember it was three years ago today.
Speaker 1: All right. So there's there Steve
Bannon with more anti-vax propaganda. We
also had a protest a number of days. He's right.
There were anti-vaccine protests over the weekend
at one of them. The big meme was about the racism
of vaccine requirements. Medical segregation is
racist. Set a sign. Stop the mandate before
it's too late. This is a new very often the
right will do this. They'll turn something on
its head and so they'll spend a decade saying
the claims of racism from the left are bogus.
The claims of racism from the left are racist
cetera. They'll do that. And then all of a sudden
they'll say, Hey, actually, hey, this is racist,
something that's not actually racist. Vaccine
requirements now are racist. Then we go to Alex
Jones once again at this Reawaken America tour,
which seems to be going on every single weekend.
Here is Alex Jones taking a sort of bizarre
kind of rapture revelation end times approach
now with the religious crowd at this event.
Speaker 4: We are literally shaking. The
book of Revelations begin to come true right in
front of us, and this is the most important time
in human history since Christ walked the Earth.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this is actually this
is getting very common. A lot of
these types that you don't always
associate with the religious naderi, we just
associate them with the kind of like more
agnostic conspiracy naderi. They are going
in the direction of jumping on board with
the religious naderi. And then speaking of
of which continuing to see trivialization
of the Holocaust at another one of these anti-vax
protests. I believe this one in New York City,
you see another one of these yellow stars go by
and I'll play that again for our audience. You can
see the yellow star kind of near the Penske truck,
which says yellow. It's a yellow star that says
unvaccinated on it, the continued trivialization
of the Holocaust, which is just kind of standard
operating procedure at this point point for
people like Marjorie Taylor Greene and others. So
every single weekend, every single weekend,
it is conspiracy. After conspiracy, we had
the Sherri Tenpenny video of her saying that
vaccinating children is a late term abortion
and that COVID testing is. Torture and on
and on and on, and it is getting really bad,
I don't know what turns this around, I really
don't. But it is extraordinarily disturbing.